there's gonna be plays like that but you
wanna make sure you keep them to an
absolute minimum
javis Colby's good right
close it over his shoulders don't look
gets it who's dad also played for the
Blazers prior to that the Timberwolves
Westbrook lost it got it back and
finished
as only Russ can that's a nice trick
shot he loses it and in the air able to
grab it with dogged defense
Kairi get this triple live tough shot
[Applause]
watch as he gets down in here he doesn't
have anything but now I'm gonna go right
up with a little fade want to touch you
because he's so smooth never a perky
jerky never in a rush that was great
[Applause]
[Applause]
so what's up LeBron they're not getting
the dunk contest three says listen
all-star week is only a couple days away
gotta be aware of the inbounder here if
you're filling
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how about the validation for Toronto
wild letters
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
which even coach status right now and
for his last two performances
never get a chance for the three-point
fire
my goodness Kevin Durant
the out of bounds play says the Brendan
Haywood excuse me I got an appointment
with the rim urine is closed to big
fella
that's a seven footer and a goop
defender as well at the top of the
circle and he blindsided from the right
corner first two jumpers present
[Applause]
[Applause]
you keep them to an absolutely
got Muscovy spins right away the
shoulder throws it over his shoulder
don't look it gets it never saw the rib
mogila 7950 one is Hooterville
31 for Kobe and that will be seen a few
more times tonight too strong
oh my goodness
gotta be kidding me look at this oh
that's ridiculous people I mean the hang
time
the exception the lane
and how about at the end of it the
concentration what is amazing